[Music]
coming up the government finally
introduces climate change as a gcse
subject adventurer bear grylls tells fyi
the government is listening we can do
something we are doing something change
is happening
[Music]
and two years since the global black
lives matter protests we meet the singer
who went viral with his song about
racism
[Music]
welcome to fyi where every week we
investigate the big stories that affect
us and this week we're gonna kick it off
with some good news yeah so after years
of campaigning by us kids environmental
groups and celebrities the government
has finally announced that climate
change will become a new gcse subject
the new natural history gcse will teach
us things like the effects of global
warming and so much more its aim is to
try and help us create our own ideas and
even get a job that involves saving the
planet
the new gcse was revealed at an event in
london and fyi was invited
so you might recognize this building yep
it's the natural history museum which
showcases everything to do with earth
and the animal kingdom what better place
for a massive announcement about efforts
to save our planet inside a press
conference the politician responsible
for our education announced we'll be
studying climate change at our schools
we will introduce a natural history gcse
giving young people a real chance to
develop a deeper knowledge and
understanding of our amazing planet
i caught up with him afterwards and i
had a burning question
why has it taken us so long to get
climate change taught as an official
subject in our schools
so
we have for a number of years now um
taught climate change in geography
in uh citizenship in
stem subjects
but i felt that we could go further
because i think young people will be
inspired i hope to become the david
attenborough of the future to become the
future
scientists and
tech entrepreneurs that save and protect
our planet the government's decision has
the backing of tv presenter and explorer
bear grylls he used to question whether
humans are really responsible for global
warming but he has definitely changed
his mind what is your biggest fear when
it comes to climate change
the pace can we can we
can we do enough
can we change it has the damage gone on
too long
[Music]
but the thing is the more clever people
i listen to the more i realize actually
it's not too late and i don't want any
young person to feel despair there's a
lot of kind of anxiety and despair but
we can do something we are doing
something change is happening i know
sometimes on the government levels it
feels glacial and slow but it is
happening and if we act now it will be
okay
so all this talk about climate change
we're going to see how much you know you
ready go for it
so what was agreeing in the paris
agreement
so we with the paris agreements to make
sure that we keep the temperature of the
earth hopefully we get to the 1.5
so how much has sea levels rose since
the 1900s my goodness that one you're
going to stump me on you're going to
tell me yes they have so far risen 21
centimeters yeah
which is dangerous
and worrying
well i don't think you did too bad there
to be honest with you it's just a shame
that the subject won't be introduced for
another three years it's annoying that
you and me will miss out but it does
mean that future generations will be
well across how we can save the planet
good point well in other news this week
there's been a lot of fuss and coverage
over the french president emmanuel
macron winning his second term in office
want to know why
[Music]
so it turns out it's been 20 years since
the french president won re-election a
lot of people didn't vote though saying
they didn't like president macron or his
opponent marine le pen
from right now
i'm no longer a candidate this is your
one particular
guide but i'm the president of everyone
my story of the week has got to be the
british success at the glorious world
sports awards tennis player emma
radakani won breakthrough of the year
award skateboarder skye brown took home
the comeback of the year award she
recovered from an injury didn't she and
bmx rider bethany shriver won the action
sports person award nice one guys
here at fyi we aim to give you a voice
with big conversations on big issues we
call it conversation
this month marks two years since the
global black lives matter protest
against racism and fyi's declan met
singer keijin bryant
this is their conversation
[Music]
i'm a young black man
[Music]
doing all that i can
in may 2020 12 year old singer kedren
bryant posted a video on social media
it went viral
[Music]
i just wanna live
the song i just wanna live which he had
written with his mother was inspired by
kedran's fear of being killed
because he is black
i just wanna leave
[Music]
i'm a young black man
it was shared by the former us president
barack obama beyonce will smith william
and many more famous black americans
it was the height of the global reaction
to the murder of the african-american
george floyd by a white police officer
his death was seen as another example of
terrible racism not just among some
police officers but across
society me as a young black man in
america it was just enlightening it just
gave me hope to keep going on and keep
spreading the message keep fighting for
what is right
the world felt that enough was enough it
was just no longer acceptable that
someone young and talented could fear
for their future in america or anywhere
in the world simply because of their
color
but two years on from george floyd's
death i want to know has anything really
changed
[Music]
i'm in jacksonville the biggest city in
the state of florida in the usa where
kedran brian and nearly 300 000 black
americans live
what i do know is that since the black
lives matter protests the lives of
kedron and his family have been
transformed
here's the moment kedran opens a gift
a professional microphone to celebrate a
recording contract with a major record
label
my life has changed i'm completely
different since i went viral
i'm going places and singing in
different interviews
i got to get signed to record label one
of records
and also just working with a lot of
other artists
[Music]
meeting um legends it's just really
impacted me in a special way because
it's always been a dream since i was
five to make people feel good inside and
just touch people's lives my gifts
so um it's it's definitely made a big
impact on my life
[Music]
the first time i heard the song when i
saw that video actually
i just found it amazing because for one
thing you're an amazing singer but also
there's
the lyrics
crazy to think that you were 12 years
old and
giving everyone who saw that video so
much insight it's definitely a lot of
fear
when you step outside the house
i want to reach everybody
across the globe not just in america
inspire other people um around the globe
because racism not only happens in just
america even though it's bigger in
america it may happen in africa
brazil
britain
[Music]
in 2021 america's new president joe
biden and the country's first african
and asian american vice president kamala
harris promised to enforce changes to
the way the police operate to combat
racism and to end discrimination in
schools colleges and workplaces
but i found a poll that shows 75 of
americans still believe their country is
racist
so since joe biden became president uh
have you seen any change in the way
things happen all has it kind of just
stayed the same
it's a small change honestly because i
don't feel as if people are as open to
being racist out in public as often like
in schools and stuff i know for myself
being a black male is just
getting pulled over by the police
so
i just try to have hope
encourage and be strong we're always
compared to
um
animals monkeys whatever you want to
call it
but
if they would just see us
as god sees us
his creation we're all humans we're all
supposed to be equal
they just don't give us a chance
kedran tells me to truly understand why
racism is such an issue we have to go
back to a bleak time in our history
hundreds of years ago when africans were
forced into slavery across the americas
kedran's home city jacksonville is named
after a u.s president who owned slaves
andrew jackson
[Music]
and just an hour's drive from here you
can see what remains of one of the
largest tobacco plantations in nearby
savannah
here hundreds of slaves from africa were
forced to work
we're meeting local historian dr stan
deaton to get more info
so we're standing on butler island
there would have been hundreds of people
at various times working out in these
rice fields enslaved people
if we're standing here on a hot wet
summer day and this would have been
typical of the kind of
weather that the enslaved people would
have had to endure as they stood out
here there were mosquitoes there were
alligators there were snakes
there'd been several families probably
to one slave cabin
so it was about as bad as you can
imagine
so how old were these slaves working out
here they would have been all ages but
once an enslaved person reached the age
of about eight they came out and began
working
[Music]
plantation owners were forced to end
slavery in 1865.
so actually being here on the actual
plantation it just makes me feel really
just emotional
yeah and to know also your ancestors
could have been here
i feel like slavery still exists but in
a modern way um police brutality even
though it may not be in the field it's
still happening so it definitely played
a big role in today's racism
kidron's right the end of slavery wasn't
the end of the fight for black people to
be treated equally
to make this point kedran used
jacksonville's oldest church to film the
video to the gospel version of i just
want to live
[Music]
it was here in 1865 that freed slaves
had to fight white people to be able to
worship here
so this church was owned by white
plantation owners
and uh
when slavery ended um they blamed black
people from ever going to this church
but then they went to court and a judge
said nope they can go in fact and they
can actually own this church wow so they
gave the church to the black people who
had been banned yeah that's really cool
but that struggle for equality went on
for generations
in the 1950s and 60s black americans
faced violence and arrest as they
demanded better treatment and equal
opportunities
change did come
and in 2008 barack obama was sworn in as
the country's first african-american
president kedron believes that moment in
history has a massive impact on young
black people today
it doesn't matter whether you're black
or white or hispanic or asian or native
american or young or old or rich or poor
able disabled gay or straight you can
make it here in america
kedron plans to use his music to inspire
young people across the world to let
nothing stand in their way of their
dreams for a better life
we have a long way to go in a long
journey ahead of us i don't know when
it's going to happen but
i believe that we can just keep on
growing and growing um until we reach
our goal
i mean wow that was really moving it was
and i think it was super eye-opening and
thought-provoking as well now if you
guys want to see more conversations just
head to first.news forward slash fyi and
click on the link plus there are details
on our website on how you can create an
fyi news club at your school and club
members can even be a guest reporter see
you next time bye
[Music]